hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here every Wednesday morning in San
Francisco California we usually have an
intro that rolls there but something's
up on the back end whatever we'll add it
later I'm your host Mike my Hardy here
as always with Peter Brown hello
reviews editor at GameSpot Rob Hanley hi
video producer and Califf laggy I'm also
an editorial with Pete in the team sorry
wow what a week kind of a [ __ ] of
a launch for Battlefront 2 I would say
to put it lightly so we'll be getting
into that what with the changes they're
making before it's official release date
which is Friday the 17th coming up soon
we're also gonna be talking more about
our extra live stream here at GameSpot
we're doing the 72-hour three days in a
row stream between the UK and Australia
offices thank you for everybody joining
in the twitch or YouTube chats I am in
both of those and on GameSpot so I feel
free to throw in some questions when you
get the chance we're gonna be talking
rocket League on switch doom on switch
Pokemon ultra and Moon ultra ultra your
Sun Moon what did I just say moon all
trends yeah Kelly your review won't have
a couple nights ago so we'll dive deeper
into that yeah
Pete you played Xenoblade Chronicles 2 a
little bit mm-hmm well you played but we
can only talk about a little bit of what
you played and yeah like I said we're
gonna talk about EA and battlefront 2
it's kind of hard not to as always we
will get into some news this week we
don't have a dedicated giveaway which we
usually do if you're new to the lobby we
usually do one of those but I will kind
of preview some of the giveaways that
we're gonna be doing all weekend on the
Extra Life livestream I'll get into this
later in the show but for those who
haven't seen our article that went up
and seen all of us talking about it
12:00 noon on November 17th we're gonna
be starting our 72-hour ignore these
photos to our stream of Palooza you can
see we got a tiny URL URL set up down
there jisse extra life 2017 go there to
donate money we're aiming for 15,000 K
this year I think we'll beat it we're
gonna be playing a lot of games I'll be
kicking it off Callie you and I will be
kicking it off noon on Friday with Sam
and Joey yeah we're gonna be playing
some Pokemon games gonna be playing I
don't know ex com-pub G let me stuff
throughout the I want to play nidhogg
yeah the new one er how to earn it help
one either both so yeah that'll be great
come hang out if you have some money to
donate the charity it's all going for us
it's all going to UCSF Benioff
Children's Hospital here in the Bay Area
but in general extra life is for Sick
Children so it's always great to help
them out for a good cause and it'll be
fun and we'll probably end up doing some
dumb things on stream as long as we're
not violating the terms of use if you
pay us enough money oh I wonder if I can
do the one piece wrap then the what I
want to do the one piece for kids wrap
one piece being an anime show for kids
being a studio that dubs
[Laughter]
that would it violate in terms of use no
no I'm gonna check from what I
understand as long as you're not like
naked or vomiting because remember we
got close to bonding last year and you
guys got close to vomiting last year
yeah
someone paid uh someone paid like gross
dollars of liquids yeah someone paid
twenty dollars to pick five ingredients
to mix together so I could eat it it was
a jalapeno bagel cream cheese schmear
soy sauce hot like very very hot sauce
milk and there was one more and I
discussed it but here's the thing I
drank like a cup and a half of it it was
gross do you remember her tongue yeah
I'm not doing that if some I'm sorry I'm
not doing that for charity but I will
sing any anime theme song oh boy and
this is before your times well we had
someone eating paper towels one year
marry kiss we'll be stopping by there
were two wrong ways of eating it well
one being don't eat paper towel I was
very like ain't like a whole bunch at
once and guide all I know in a nice like
fall and then like choked on it just
like pushed it yeah it's not how I eat
you eat paper towels
yeah Marrakesh former gamespot priests
will be stopping by for like four hours
at some point on Friday and then Tim
Torre who who works at Capcom good
friend of ours here he does some stuff
with resin evil but he also used to be
Game Informer if you know him he'll be
stopping by we'll have a few guests a
lot of Giveaways
I'll talk about those later on the show
but first let's get to the news of the
week some of
this is from last week apologies if it's
kind of dated respawn the studio robbed
you and I know and love dura developer
of titanfall titanfall 2 was acquired by
EA so they were published by EA
previously now EA it's an internal
studio for 400 million u.s. dollars so
here's how it went down necks on a South
Korean like publisher gaming
conglomerate wanted to buy respawn EA
had like some sort of contract that
allowed them to counter it and they did
and they got it this happened the
timeline gets fuzzy because people were
like did this happened before or after
they sold visceral shuddered visceral
but apparently the timeline is they
shuttered visceral and then bought
respawn so titanfall 3 also got
announced kind of a bittersweet thing if
this week with Battlefront 2 is anything
to go by I'm kind of worried about
titanfall 3 what's gonna happen with
presumably like every other EA game
there will be some sort of
microtransactions despite the fact that
titanfall 2 was we talk about all the
time as an example of how to do post
release right with free Maps free you
know all the micro transactions are
aesthetic right all the type prime
Titans all the cosmetic items are all
micro transactions but the game is
simple enough and not confusing enough
and what did Nick say that one time
girthy enough with half of my grades and
yes this game thankfully was girthy and
long enough actions that you know have
to worry about them but Rob as a
titanfall 2 fan I think that was your
one or two game of the year two years
ago my game of the year was your game of
the year what is this is worried you
about titanfall 3 based on what's
happening with battlefront 2 and
everything around EA sure it does
because I think one of the problems and
that I mean as well as that game coming
in between two other huge triple-a
shooters right it was it had a rough
launch had a rough time game praised I
feel like it was a underrated game but
the there microtransaction system I
don't think gave them that much money it
was all purely cosmetics but there you
know it I thought it was done perfectly
for me
I mean I still gave money because I
adored that game and I felt just
justifiable to give money and buy a
cool-looking tighten skin or whatnot
I mean importantly you knew what you
were getting yeah yeah it wasn't it
wasn't there weren't a gamble yeah
exactly
okay $5.00 for this scorched skin so
what what I am just praying I don't see
is prepare for create fall it seems
inevitable though I mean look at all the
opportunity if you're if you are EA if
you're one of the people who made the
decision to do this to battlefront 2
you're looking at titanfall 2 you're
seeing all kinds of opportunities for
cosmetic items with the Titans with the
pilots based on battlefront 2 you're
also seeing opportunities to maybe say
like oh what if this card buffs scorches
flame shield you know assuming sports in
titanfall 3 that would be the worst-case
scenario right and it was such a weird
because I was like oh titanfall 3 is
happening that's good because I wasn't
positive I know titanfall 2 did ok but
like you said it wasn't I didn't think
it did gangbusters but ea cared enough
about it to buy respawn and make him an
internal studio mm-hmm I'm I mean I was
surprised this happened but I don't know
you know silver lining is titanfall 3 is
gonna happen but like you said
worst-case scenario it might be almost
pay2win like battlefront is battlefront
2 is this week which we're kind of
already talking about anyway yeah I'd
like to think that read the guys at
respawn have a pretty good grip of yeah
their own franchise right it's not their
call though yeah I know it's not their
call I'm just saying like I just I hope
that they can defend themselves you know
I mean I wonder if titanfall 2 really
didn't do well and this was the only way
they could have made money off of it if
EA bought them and said like we're gonna
do this stuff with titanfall 3 to make
money back off of buying your franchise
I mean at that point we're just like
wildly speculating great we really don't
know and we really don't know what their
intention is Vaughn we we don't know
that they want to implement a similar
sort of thing I mean like we can we can
probably guess that right based on what
EA does but I don't yeah probably
emphasize that we don't know any
yeah it would be the difference of
whether the outcry of the no court
gaming audience is going to be enough to
offset their desire for money yeah yeah
and there's obviously people who buy
games who don't like who aren't involved
in like we were talking about before the
show who aren't involved in gaming
communities who don't go on reddit or on
GameSpot who who are just like they're
the people who are going to buy those
microtransactions so like I don't know I
it depends how how it performs in in
other games I think it's also crazy to
think that like it just by looking at
like battlefront and how that game was
rolling out and how you know we saw cult
trailers and for me at least there was
generally you know an amount of hype
that won with that and then at what
point did the the progression and
lootcrate systems start kind of rolling
out you know I mean like it takes then I
feel like a year to then see that you
know what I mean so it's like you can
never I just feel like you can never
really see a game until it's fairly
close to to launch right and that's
where for me at least is like I've just
a crazy titanfall fan like I just feel
like I have to like bite my lip until I
can at least you know have like a
relaxed feeling about a game I don't
know yeah people are blaming the horse
armor from Skyrim for more news story I
want to get through before we get into
the main topics today vaulting went to
player unknowns battlegrounds and the
test servers which if you play it often
you know how big of a deal that is
relatively because previously you had to
run sideways sprint to jump over low
enough walls but now it's out there I
think Jake and Nick were playing the
other night I don't know if we have any
gameplay off of it yeah play every night
yeah yeah but I don't I'm trying to
remember I don't think it confuse me
because Nick's name on the test servers
is Michael hi I'm no that's on the test
servers he's Michael hi so I thought it
was Michael I'm playing but yeah they
were playing AI yeah it's pretty much
like an actual action to vault over
things now and then they like mate you
mean like mantling sort of order yeah
yeah as opposed to before you had to do
this weird sideways sprint often so you
had to like do so
she's it yeah yeah and also the desert
map more details about the desert map
were leaked as well as vehicles it'll
come to the desert map it'll be going to
Xbox early access in December but they
pushed the full release to next year
apparently which isn't too surprising
they've been kind of no one knows when
it's happening now that's leads to the
interesting discussion around whether we
you consider pop G like a released game
well it's even worse because it's early
access on xbox but the 1.0 which is what
you name your you know ready to be
released game is coming out on PC yeah
so it'll have a final release on PC this
year right access xbox this year so yeah
so it'll still technically be a PC
exclusive in the sense that it's a full
game this year yeah it gets it's so
weird thinking about how you even
classify games now it's because at this
point pub Jesus early access but we were
talking today about all the games that
it's cleaner than like when Mass Effect
Andromeda released that was a mess like
obviously you paid $60 for that that was
from a Bioware Montreal but it's just
weird thinking about how things have
changed hopefully when that went into
first early access to was that launch if
that's what you would call was that like
fairly stable and everything like that
fairly yeah I think the reason pub G is
so successful it's not it's nowhere near
the first game to do what it's doing
like the fifth and it's spawned off of
you know ARMA 2 dayz it's just stable I
wouldn't say it's it's not like
gorgeous-looking it's not like David
Daisy wasn't even stable that's down
alone so like I mean in compared to that
I would read and puppy was way better
yeah yeah that's one say like pub GE
works has worked well so often I think
people play it all the time is because
it's pretty reliable and consistent
you'll see there'll be games where like
you won't see buildings but that's a few
and far between I really would like it
to be more optimized though because I am
putting off buying a new graphics card
for money and it just doesn't work oh my
my home PC I I would have to play in the
office so that's what that is the one
thing that bothers me about the early
access game is that like it doesn't
require like you shouldn't require like
a 1070 or whatever but yeah it's not
optimized might as well I have I mean my
mine's pretty old mine's from 2013 it's
like 6f
so it's like not gonna run a lot of
things super well but I still think it's
not graphically demanding enough to
warrant me having to buy a new one
that's that that's my one thing that is
irritating with the really access stuff
is the Xbox version appealing to you in
that sense that it's just already
optimized for that device yeah I mean
because I already have an Xbox and I
wouldn't have to buy anything new except
for a copy of funky but I've already
purchased I bought the $30 version on
Steam so I mean I was going to upgrade
my graphics card anyway so it's like a
stupid complaint really but it's like oh
now I feel like I have to do it now
because I want to play it before Game of
the Year stuff yeah we talked about it
you know I liked what I've played a pup
gee yeah it's got its fans to say the
least obviously but it still becomes
this weird gray area we're like what
does it even mean to be a fully released
game anymore yeah but anyway moving on
to our bigger segments today we are
gonna get to Pokemon Xenoblade
Chronicles in battlefront to probably
talk most about battlefront 2 and EA but
first Pete you put up a review yesterday
for rocket League on switch most people
in the GameSpot office are fans of
rocket League that was kind of our 5
p.m. game for quite a long time for a
couple years now it's coming to
Nintendo's console another example of
how third parties are supporting
Nintendo on the switch how's it play
how's it look what's going on with this
here game uh it looks like it's a port
to a lesser platform than the ones it
was created for more importantly it
doesn't play like it it plays exactly
like the way you remember it and it's
got you know the portability factor
going on and you can even play with a
single joique on if you want and there's
like I think like one command on the
controller that's not there but it
freakin works yeah yeah you're not able
to do like the quick chat on a joy con
because you're missing like a second
kind of deep a - sure yeah and you can
flip to the secondary camera mode where
it's like a free camera but it's not
actually free moving you can only just
face forward as opposed to the other
mode which is always focused on the ball
but yeah I mean you're looking at the
switch version here that's my 6h car
that's a sick goal and it's um I mean
you know what's important here is frame
rate what's important as controls
what's important is online functionality
and all that stuff just work
um you know and even the graphic stuff
as much as I can you know look at it and
say yeah this kinda looks like [ __ ] once
in a while it doesn't matter this game
doesn't need to look good to play well I
think I said just someone yesterday like
this thing was a brick I was saying to
you
okay I don't care if this thing looks
like a brick yeah I would still play it
yeah you're saying the frame rates the
most important thing here and that's not
affected at all on a switch no I haven't
seen any issues there so you said a
plays well poor and portable like if
you're playing multiplayer does it feel
I was talking about this this game is so
reliant on it's almost flawless
mechanics and how you use them yeah
having the portable thing instead of a
pro controller always seems questionable
to me it's same with when you're talking
about doom on switch which we're gonna
talk about shortly yeah games that rely
on their mechanics it's always weird to
have that much space between the analog
stick so when you're holding it um yeah
that feels fine it's well it takes some
time to get used to it but I'd say like
you know four or five matches in and
you're not really thinking about it
anymore the yeah the one thing that I
ran into that Eric T also mentioned so
this game doesn't really have any
anti-aliasing which means a lot of the
3d models are jagged looking you can I
hear it doesn't seem to have great depth
of field processing so what that means
basic when you're playing on handheld
mode is that something way on the
opposite end of the court let's say
you're you know protecting your goal and
you're looking at the opponent's goal
from the other end the jaggies will
appear consistently large for distant
objects and close objects so that can be
an issue if say someone gets the right
shot to send the ball flying directly at
you like when you're looking at it
because then you just can't really judge
the speed of it all that well but that
that's the thing that pops up like two
or three times for me across like 20
matches unhandled yeah like I haven't
happened I haven't had it happened to me
and I've put a decent mount of ours and
but I could I could see that yeah when
it's flying so fast from across field
right where your yeah just an shil thing
definitely you know but yeah and to
touch on like the controls like I you
know I haven't played doom switch but
you know the one of the complaints with
that game is you know the portable
factor of using the toy cons and you
know for a game like that which really
does require as you know as a
first-person shooter like
really you know precise movements of the
joystick I could see that getting
frustrating using a USB keyboard because
unfortunately like you know the there is
no quick chat with like ps4 right that
has like the auto text kind of thing
right but also yeah when you load up the
keyboard on ps4 it'll keep the game
running in the background with your
keyboard being somewhat transparent when
you open up the the keyboard to chat on
switch you can't see what's actually
happening on-screen right you can't chat
before a match dumb [ __ ] you can still
say the things that are automap to your
d-pad yeah those work just the same
there are some yes so there are some
small compromises to be made here but
you know the core that really counts is
present and functions and oh just a
touch on what I was trying to say was
that like with the joy cons I played a
decent amount handheld and you could you
could kind of like get a sense of the
length of like you know like I can see
myself getting better at the joy cons
and having it handheld what single joy
Khan is still pretty difficult but like
handle it was like oh I'm getting the
hang of this you know the one thing
would be like in Ariel like you know in
Ariel play where you are really like
reliant on like ultra precise like car
positioning like you could see yourself
just getting better at that handheld and
then on a controller it's great I'm just
gonna say I wonder how many people are
playing this and then I forgot it's the
cross play with Xbox and PC audience so
there were 80,000 people playing on the
night it launched on switch don't you
forget it don't know how many those
people were playing on switch per se but
obviously unless you're playing on ps4
you're not gated off from the other
communities that's still Sony's choice
like psionics is always saying literally
we would check a box on this webpage and
Sony will be able to play with Microsoft
players and PC as well and you are able
to turn off cross-platform and just play
the switch owners yeah those minor
problems feel like it's sure like if you
feel like you're getting worked or you
have that like resentment of like Oh
someone on Xbox or pcs having a better
experience oh yeah you can do it you can
do that as well as and we test it on a
live stream you what you do have the
ability to do the private servers it
doesn't seem like you can match with
someone who was on an Xbox
or PC because that requires like being
friends with them mm-hm - my understood
in matchmaking but in matchmaking you
can do private matches just like here's
the code or like you know let me let me
like team up with or play with other
people under the platform's PC or Xbox
so I'm terrible at rocket League because
I played it on PC and I don't know the
controls not work for me and I'm very
bad at it so I would happily play with
other people
cross-platform and just pretend that
playing the switch yeah was making me
bad like a mouse and keyboard and PC is
that way yeah I was yeah that is good
I'm happy like it's just bodes well for
rocket League which you know like the
team at psyonix does great work over
there and I'm I'm glad that the switch
is continuing to get third-party support
any last minute you want I mean like you
have your review up on GameSpot if you
want to go read that on GameSpot or
watch it on YouTube the video review is
up there as well
yeah any last-minute thoughts Peter
plugging Roger let you wait today I
should probably play like you a proper
GameSpot employee it's vital for game of
the year
no I'm joking I just really we all like
really what's funny is that when rocket
league first came out and we were jr.
gave me that year debates it was pretty
much for the second and third slot
between rocket league and Metal Gear
Solid 5 and what was you gave Metal Gear
a 10 and very very adamant about it well
yes and while I enjoyed rocket League at
the time I didn't I hadn't put as much
time into it as I as I have at this
point and I'm curious how that debate
would look now coming from me I love
thinking about that very very personal
and testing room where people are really
arguing it's like really you're gonna do
that like you're gonna pick a game I've
yelled at people and be in the air that
was before it gets yeah but it is
interesting to like think about that
game because I had resentments - who's
like does rocket League deserve like ok
let me think about it like that
that's who didn't even make it out of
the ambulance you were vicious on switch
you play Doom recently
fare as well as rocket League no overall
but still good I'd still recommend
playing it if you haven't played doom
it's it's a little bit it's a tough pill
to swallow it's 60 bucks I got to say
for ya I did not know this was $60 until
right before the game came out nobody I
talked to did it like snow they're like
you mean $30 right yeah like nope and
it's the same with Skyrim that's also a
full price game and it's like okay like
I guess I can see the thinking behind it
but but that being that it's switch and
switches hot and people will buy games
for switch I mean I I understand $60 for
do more than Skyrim Skyrim is six years
old but whatever yeah just side note but
like you can buy doom for 20 bucks
anywhere right that's true yeah on other
platforms yeah and I also just haven't
played both these games extensively
especially Skyrim Skyrim I care less
about visuals and mechanical finesse of
the game and doom I think that's all
they're not all there is but that's a
huge part of it but how do is aesthetic
is a huge part of that game right and
that's sort of something I like quietly
addressed my rocket League review which
is that like okay well this actually
don't me the same studio that did the
port for rocket League so it's a really
interesting point of comparison for what
that studio can be a panic button is
their name so yeah like unlike rocket
League you don't need the world to look
great for you to buy into the things
that you're doing we're in doom that
certainly helps sell like this sort of
like you know feverish thrill of hunting
down demons in hell
you know when hell starts to look like
something out of cardboard maybe that
whatever immersion you're experiencing
as a you know doom Slayer just kind of
like doesn't it just feel slightly
diminished but like you know doom is
also great action so if you can kind of
see through the the poor textures and
the strange resolution switches you can
still really get into the game and enjoy
it which is why I got the you know a
positive score from us even if it's not
as high as the other versions yeah how
does it feel I'm trying to think outside
from splatoon to obviously which is the
first party or which is a Nintendo title
on the switch in a third-person shooter
right
what would you how it is this kind of a
good indicator of the future of
first-person shooters on switch or just
kind of make you
weary or I think it shows that they can
work I think handheld is maybe the one
thing that really needs to be worked on
or refined in some way because you know
despite trying to change camera
sensitivities and you know how the
controls really functioned I still found
myself struggling with the the very
small joysticks on their analog sticks
on the the Joye cons when playing
handheld and that was something that I I
got used to but I never felt like I was
playing at the same level of scale and
efficiency as I was otherwise I'll also
say to your question Mike that like doom
I love 2016 doom I think it's it depends
on the type of first-person shooter I
mean this game is very much like kill
chamber constant movement like forward
movement specifically yeah like you're I
would like when I played this game I
played on xbox just constant movement
kind of like always facing the center of
the room and moving in the perimeter
kind of movement so I think it depends
also on the style of first-person
shooter you're playing and I'm
interested to see how Wolfenstein 2
plays on switch yeah because that's
another sort of it has some classic
shooter elements because it is based on
another ed software titles so I am
curious as well because I mean doom
encourage you to keep moving and be
aggressive even when your health slows
encourage you to do glory kills
Wolfenstein encourage you to be
aggressive cuz the enemies are pretty
smart and flanking you but you do have
to take cover every once in a while and
kind of game really slow yeah
stealth as well before you even kind of
start a firefight but yeah Doom is such
a weird I'm glad it came to switch and
like I said rocket League he's on switch
like wolf sign to next year and Bethesda
is like heavily supporting their games
coming to switch but doom seems a weird
game to start off with it makes sense
chronologically because it came out in
2016 long before Wolfenstein 2 which
will come out next year on switch but it
does seem like it I don't know just I
can't wrap my head around a game like
this being on handheld and you said that
same thing it's just such a when you're
playing with a controller that wide I
realized this is pedantic but your
center of gravity between your hands if
that makes sense is so off but like I
couldn't know why the n64 controller has
that extra prong is special
like just like Nintendo controllers
having a weird like center of gravity
and you're here yeah like not a new
thing and splatoon work whatever you
want say about the motion controls those
felt good with splatoon right I actually
played splatoon too almost entirely on
handle handles and I felt good right
yeah great for this switch right and
it's it's I think that's another thing
as platoon 2 is a shooter yes but it's a
very different flavor of shooter so I
don't think it's some one-to-one
comparison by any other I love that
Bethesda is supporting the switch
definitely and that third party or and
like just I don't know I I feel like
this is a game Doom especially as it is
a game that Nintendo the Nintendo of
maybe 10 years ago would have shied away
from really heavily yeah and that's
encouraging to me as well they're kind
of like over that family-friendly only
phase from what we're getting now I
don't know what I'm say it's yeah it is
encouraging I'm just I'm curious like
how how long the lifespan of
first-person shooters on a switch is
unless they just keep figuring it out on
iterating on it which hopefully is the
case because website doesn't have a
release date yet but it's next year at
some point 2018 see if it be a good
reason to replay it but did you put
multiplayer on doom switch - how was
that looks far worse yeah which is
framerate everything in general most of
the resolution of textures and 3d models
are really low it looks like a early ps2
game
yeah but it functions and there really
isn't anything like it on switch I mean
there's even if you think of substantive
splatoon very different you know aims as
it were competitive gaming so you think
it's an important audience for Nintendo
I mean outside of splatoon - there
aren't many other there's no other like
first party shooter that everyone is
important to Nintendo well Metro Fran
when it comes out right that's a good
much repent for yeah but as far as I
don't know I'm on Metro prime as a
shooter but I'd almost put that in
different its I mean yeah like I said on
you know I wouldn't put all first-person
shooters in the same basket well they
figured out how to make prime corruption
feel great on the weak if you played
that it's it feels great despite like
motion controls and whatnot and also
like we like we're talking as people who
really like first-person shooters and
play a lot of shooters I think maybe
there is and I don't know if I would
consider doom to be that game but maybe
there is a place for like somebody who's
maybe not as industry ters but it's
interested in them or if they only owned
a switch and no you see yeah I just want
to like play a little bit who aren't
really interested in multiplayer maybe
because it sounds like that's probably
where Doom is at its worst on switch
yeah but you said we can't explain that
you're not playing multiplayer I did not
[Laughter]
say something about Metroid Prime I was
going to and then I forgot oh I'm sorry
more so switches $60 it's out as of
Friday sure cool I yeah you can go check
that off you haven't played it or if you
want to replay it on now that you've got
your switch up and running and you
haven't played it since maybe 2016
fantastic shooter some small problems on
the switch some bigger but go check it
out that's pretty much it for new switch
games Skyrim on switches coming out
Friday actually yeah alongside
battlefront two in the same day
can we talk about Skyrim on switch all
yep nope no but we can talk about Zulu
Mike which is all we can aim we can in a
little bit you said that's it for new
switch games I know well we're gonna
talk about Pokemon 3d s3s stuff and then
come back to you switch games oh right
no we're not going back to new switch
games just kidding
you know like Chronicles 2 will just
jump right into that's as good as that's
it's terrible of a segue as any
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 you know like is
this the next big ARP well it is the
next big RPG on switch but you think
this is the next great switch entry nope
really no based on what you played not
not yet anyway I haven't gotten that
sense yet what this feels like is an
extension a slight you know retooling of
what Xenoblade Chronicles has always
been which is good in a sense but you
know it comes with a lot of caveats
that I think people may you know if they
are expecting this to be the next
flagship switch game and they pick it up
because they think oh it'll just be fine
this is my next Mario or my next Elda
they might realize oh wait this is like
you know this shows signs of maybe the
least like you know universally you know
loved tendencies of Japanese development
yeah so you know you will see a lot of
like really strange anime trope type
things in here that sort of butt heads
with the tone that they're really trying
to establish or the story they're trying
to make you care about you know there's
there's just certain things that also
are a bit low Phi and a bit janky that
you know you look at Western RPGs or
even some of the better Japanese RPGs
and you're like oh they put more effort
into making this feel like a more modern
experience but if you know if you're if
you know that you're someone who likes
the series already or if you enjoyed you
know RPGs from Japan pretty much in
general I think you're safe to look
forward to this game you know like I
said I have a couple misgivings with it
so far but I'm still looking forward to
playing it because what you know what
the things that this game does really
well are intact which is putting you in
these very large worlds which with large
you know selections of monsters some of
which you know that you know you'll run
underfoot and you're like I can't fight
that guy from there forty hours and
you're either hanging out with them
already or you're trying to avoid him
and you know it's just the sort of sense
of exploration in combat that the flow
if you will that works so well and the
game is a few things new you you know
that girl behind you Paris she is your
your blade even though you also have a
blade yeah they're like familiars I
think they're like great Millers but
they're also persona and know they're
it's like they're familiars but they're
not because they seem like tangible
things on their own
but they're also born from crystals so
it's it's hard to it's really hard to
say if they're familiar or not a
familiar they are essentially a strange
sidekick do all of them have the weird
pants that aren't pants no I mean that
that's another thing right there I mean
it's like you can see 60% of her butt
crack
it doesn't make any sense and it's just
when it's just one of those stylistic
choices that works for a particular type
of audience but if you're not into that
you have to deal with it if you're gonna
enjoy this game it's not the end of the
world but it doesn't necessarily like do
the game any favors let's see yeah I
really I don't really care about that
it's funny right no reason she has this
weird song sticking out it's just it's
just kind of lame so the essentially
blades function you know as sort of like
an ability tree for you and like your
support in combat as well so they
determine what sort of abilities you can
cast during battle and you can swap
between three different blades on the
fly there's actually a lot to talk about
with combat so if I was really trying to
dig into it we'd be here forever and
that's actually one of the strange
things about the game is that hours in
you're still getting tutorial messages
and the sartorial messages are framed as
though there's a narrator you guys I'm
gonna take a minute to tell you about
this thing like the narrator and
Moonrise Kingdom on new Penzance that's
like the duncan realm narrator except
that game is supposed to be like that I
mean technically it's not like a verbal
narration it's a that was much more apt
sorry I was I was going Wes Anderson
mode for a second it's all text-based
stuff but yeah it's just kind of strange
and you know I will say it's almost
correcting one of the wrongs was you
know but Chronicles X the previous game
which was obtuse with some of its
systems to the point that you'd have to
dig through the manual which is in the
end of the world but you know anyway now
they've kind of tried to course-correct
a bit and it might be too heavy-handed
at the start but I'm still pretty early
into the game like this is probably a 70
80 hour game I'm a little less than
eight hours in right now so I've got it
you know quite a ways to go but I am
enjoying it despite my misgivings the
one thing that I can't get over is the
voice acting it is atrocious
oh no the localization is I don't know
probably fine but it's the the void like
the actors behind the voices especially
the main character Rex it's it's just
bad it's it's why
um wait I like this cat girl she's cool
she's all right
like actually I'll get to what this sort
of scene does do well in a second but
like so for example like you know you're
running into combat and there's like
this big dramatic moment where you feel
empowered you should be like really the
guys like just like he was like am I
allowed to you in this booth go for it
he's like I just feel bad yelling like I
feel like there's like first take type
stuff like no that's perfect no yeah it
does seem that way and it doesn't see
and it seems like yeah like and in that
same vein you know there's a line that
you're reading or you're hearing and
you're like the way that that's phrased
should carry your certain emotion with
it and this character just doesn't
deliver that and so you constantly feel
like the the script is actually
undermined by the acting you know behind
the characters the cutscenes though are
still enjoyable because you get these
sort of and these are the best of the
series has been so far these like little
little story sequences that that's sort
of like use anime type tropes in a good
way for light-hearted humor stuff right
it's just when the game tries to be
serious but it also has you know a furry
egg speaking in third-person about
itself trying to make a joke now I'm
starting to start to lose sight of what
it's really trying to accomplish the
furry egg wasn't that from the last game
it's they've been in every game it's
this series of characters known as nopon
they are the the Furby of you know this
universe and they're back they they're
it's an easy way to just sort of SAP
away any sort of like serious connection
with what's happening you know I was
mentioning earlier sort of like this the
the aged things that this game presents
like idle animations when characters are
just standing by during a discussion
people are just breathing heavily and
like swaying their arms I know that game
you just sort of look at it and you're
like right like this is this is not a a
refined modern RPG this is a refined
yesteryear RPG which isn't the end of
the world
you've got to know what you're getting
yourself into yeah it's a shame I mean
like you said you haven't finished it
but I was kind of hoping to hear more
praise because aside from Pokemon the
switch exclusive sometime next year
presumably and the shin megami tensei 5
have a release date yet I don't that's
just next year right those are the next
two big RPGs I can think of on the
switch just kind of hoping that that
simply chronicles 2 releases on December
1st of this year so like what 2 weeks
away
I'm kinda hoping that this would fill
that gap especially because you had good
things to say about Xenoblade Chronicles
X in the way you write I good things to
say about that yeah and even X I had a
lot of problems with but ISIL ended up
giving that game in 8th because it was
the the issues that I had with that game
primarily were again stylistic choices
and in only some respects did I feel
like those betrayed what the game you
know it's it's stronger suits
I felt that need to mention them because
they annoyed me yeah but ultimately I
still found a great game worth playing
and right now I still think that this is
a game that I personally look forward to
because I come from a background that
used to like maybe the things this game
does now that I no longer like but I can
understand why they're there and look
past them in a way except the voice
acting that I've literally I've
literally muted the game there's no
voice acting unless I'm in a scene
unless I'm in a cutscene recording for
footage it's that annoying but but on
launch day they are releasing the
Japanese voice pack if experience is
anything to go by it's not just oh is
Japanese games alrighty the Japanese
voices no it's that Japanese voice
actors tend to convey far more emotion
even if I don't understand what they're
saying I can feel the weight of the line
they're delivering far more than I can
so far in this game with its cast
especially when you're playing a game
that relies on anime tropes to because
those things can be over the top in a
way that like English voice acting
sometimes it just sounds so cheesy like
the scream they're like ah like I just
feel like there's certain things that
don't work because they don't translate
one to one in some respects and that's
not the fault of localization that's
just like the stylistic thing that for
me is very jarring I understand people
who like dubs but it's weird for me I
think the core issue is that the
Japanese voice actors are probably far
more familiar with the people making the
game one
game actually is versus what I imagine
is a team of British voice actors in
England receiving a script and being
potentially directed by someone but
there as you know it would just stand to
reason that they don't really know the
context of what they're reading like
they don't understand maybe the gravity
that of the situation's these characters
are facing or they do when they're just
bad voice actors and they don't know how
to accomplish the goals that they set
out to but there is certainly some
divide present between the the amount of
effort put into what's happening around
you and what seems to be a lack of
understanding from the actors persona
five earlier this year like the English
voice acting they didn't know how to
pronounce half the Japanese name rightly
so that shouldn't happen if there's
someone to hide to the game who is
nearby can say
excuse me over the mic yes I just want
to tell you that you're pronouncing that
wrong yeah thank you my mo it's all it
takes the most exposure I have to like
Japan Japanese culture and Japanese the
language is through games and I knew how
to pronounce half of those and the paid
voice actors didn't but the the Japanese
voice actors came out and you could
download that and everybody says they
were much much better same thing with
this I guess but uh so any last thoughts
that you can talk about this point
before we get toward the grand people
yeah and it's a whole race of things
that exists in looks like a what do want
to call it from last Jedi trailer poor
ye Oh God
yeah only I've never seen ears as hands
before and it's blowing my mind is that
what are they dentists ears
yeah his his ears are Pollan lovers no I
don't hate him cuz he's silent right now
it helps really helps that's gonna
become I feel like I've heard so many
lines in this game that are going to
become memes because there's no that
it's just like yeah like it might as
well be that wizard came from the moon
it's just like
all right well your full review for
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 will be up closer
to December first yeah yeah
mixed impression so far all right well
moving on to another RPG this time on
the 3ds Pokemon ultrasone an ultra moon
the release of the 2015 Pokemon game
correct
I wouldn't say it's a rerelease its
pokemon has been doing weird things with
the likes equally titles in their
generations so like generation 1 is like
red and blue and then they released
yellow like a year later in the US and
so they've been doing that since the
beginning with black 2 and white 2 they
did direct sequels and with this
generation which is the seventh
generation of Pokemon games they did
sort of like a definitive version of Sun
and Moon so it had it adds Pokemon to
the Pokedex to the National pokedex that
you can choose from and it makes some
tweaks so the biggest thing for me is a
complaint a common complaint I heard
about Sun and Moon was at the beginning
was excruciatingly Li slow and I think
Mike you kind of echoed this when we're
talking about exterior like you didn't
speak very favorably of Sun and Moon and
it sounded like you couldn't get through
that opening which I don't blame you so
the opening is a lot I did but it took
some effort yeah um so yeah basically in
Sun and Moon you have to go through like
a bunch of different cutscenes and like
meet like ten different people before
you even get your starter Pokemon and
they just totally reverse that and got
rid of a bunch of the expository garbage
that nobody cares about so you get your
post are two Pokemon right away and I
was like oh we're getting right into
this like I was so pleasantly surprised
and it gets rid of that handhold the
feeling of like okay we're walking and
we're meeting my mom we're walking and
we're meeting the professor like it let
me roam immediately which I really liked
and so it definitely felt like they were
like alright I think we all by now
everybody knows how to play Pokemon so
we're just gonna let you do that it felt
it was a relief for me and then there's
just like quality of life improvements
with ultrasound and ultra moon that just
make things
slightly more streamlined they tweaked
some of the trials which is this
generations take on gyms so instead of
going from like gym to gym to the Elite
Four you do these like trial activities
which involves battling poke mom but
also like little puzzle II things which
is a nice change of pace and they they
tweaked some of those look some of the
more chore like ones like there's one we
have to fetch three ingredients for ass
to go in the cave or yeah you're know
you're in a you're in like a meadow
forest thing you should like fetch three
ingredients and they changed it where
you have to like try to figure out which
like there's an area with like a bunch
of sudowoodo like the tree Pokemon and
like one of them is just a tree and the
rest are Pokemon you kind of have like
figure out which one is which and it's
the spots on the tree yes there's stuff
like that and just like um you can pet
the dog which is like ace unfortunately
we can't show any footage because of
embargoes um what else did they change
oh I will say that the the ink the
addition of new Pokemon that weren't in
Sun and Moon in the National pokedex is
really good for competitive players I
always try to keep this in mind because
I really like the competitive meta game
of Pokemon and anything that tweaks that
meta game and keeps it fresh and
interesting is important to me and so it
seems like they take that into account
as well as some of the more casual
players so I think they're it's good I
liked it nice so for someone like myself
who thought moon was alright sunny moon
were alright is this a like a try give
it a second chance now is there are
there enough changes here that it would
change my mind potentially um I mean
last time I talked to you you said it
was worse than alright so I carry
probably be negative like three-quarters
the way through the game okay I played a
lot of it um I think what do you think
if people were I don't know if I
recommend it to somebody who didn't like
Senate moon okay because it is a very
similar game they changed some of the
story beats
so there's like a new antagonist it ends
up making it more confusing so it's like
I don't really play pokemon for the
story anyway I don't know if there's
enough changes to the actual like
structure of the game to be like if you
like hated the trials or something like
that but if you were like oh I have to
do this chore like thing it this is kind
of a slog this thing I have to do then
this fixes all of that for you are you
you're into the competitive space with
Pokemon right yeah you pay attention to
it I don't know if you play I play yeah
breathe every Pokemon and I play
competitively forgive me if you already
kind of touched on it someone was asked
Potsie 1996 and now the YouTube chat was
saying like with the competitive space
so there are many major changes yes so
in addition to the new Pokemon the
Pokedex they added move tutors and
they're so excited about this it was too
much weight tutors or sorry waiters just
fart I didn't mean to spark this word
association sorry Kelly this is too nice
for the review but I did mention this on
Twitter I'm very excited because in Sun
and Moon they didn't have that many move
tutors which is a person it's a place
you can go to and with battle points
which you amass through the kind of
competitive channels within the game
forget if it's called I think it's the
battle tree in Sun and Moon but you get
battle points and it's like a different
currency and you can teach your Pokemon
moves that they couldn't learn naturally
or through TMS and they didn't have that
many in Sun and Moon which meant my
Umbreon was completely useless and so
they added a bunch and there's like a
surfing minigame that you can play
tied to it I talked to an NPC that said
something about surfing Pikachu's I need
to check that out so there's there's a
lot of stuff I think for the super
involved Pokemon player as well and then
then there's this which I can't talk
about right now unfortunately other than
what we are literally looking at right
now okay but yeah there you can check
out Pokemon to rent try them out which
is
also really cool for competitive players
who maybe don't have access to legendary
Pokemon and want to try movesets before
committing to it legendary Pokemon
because because you can only catch those
once and you'd have to restart the whole
game in order to change it unless you
hacked it which you should not do
I'm same way all stopped did you say you
can't talk about something we're seeing
isn't your review up or do they have a
weird embargo because the embargo is
complicated so I can't see any game
things like I can't say any more about
this than what you are literally looking
at this boy is considered okay there's
Mewtwo there he is mu also I know him
yeah that's good those good boy that's
the Rayquaza cool I always need my
Rayquaza Paarthurnax after the Dragon
and Skyrim just side note oh [ __ ] it's
not it barely fits man
alright last minute things you still can
talk about about pokemons ultrasone and
ultramoon um yeah just to wrap up I
think this is definitely like for me I
think generation 7 does so much to make
it welcoming to both the more casual
player the beginner player and also the
super hardcore competitive player that's
really focused on the end game and so
from my perspective these generations do
a lot to to improve that experience all
around and so for older son ultramoon i
think they just add the necessary tweaks
to to refine that and so i am really
happy about it and i'm excited about i
don't don't know if this is yes this is
me accusing me meuk is my favorite
pokemon they added a new move called
let's snuggle forever this is this is
borderline disturbing did someone draw a
face on that Pokemon use new ultra what
is it ultra Mitzie move he just he just
puts his skirt lower half his body over
pokemon and then something terrible
happens to them inside it and then poop
them out like stomach acid get some view
down me Q is a ghost fairy-type pokémon
that just wants to be loved and so and
care it giraffe dresses up as a Pikachu
but it's not very artistic so it's
outfit is very bad but that's why I love
it it just wants to be your friend
so go play pokemon ultrasone altar moon
if you liked past versions this is the
definitive version to play is the best
Pokemon ever
whoa heart is your heart belong in the
Pokemon my favorite Pokemon game is
pokemon crystal I didn't play that one I
just want a Pokemon game where you got
fourth generation second generation Oh
sound smart I figured I have like a one
in six chance uh it's the one it's a
wadis legacy in Pokemon is that he made
it so you could go to Kanto after chotto
oh yeah Jake loved that game to know his
favorites first generation gentoos the
best generation though I play gen -
listen to me okay I got a question how
many Pokemon are there now uh 725 I
think it's like either it's either 700
when T or 740 I can't I don't know the
exact number still more core exceeds
there's still more core oxys than there
are Pokemon cha so you could collect all
the Pokemon probably faster than the car
seat actually I would love to see a
comparison
you could probably collect every Pokemon
faster than you get Darth Vader and
battlefront - alright actually that's a
good segue to comes out officially
tomorrow night Friday November 17 unless
you paid for the 80 or $90 yet maybe
then buy it now even in stores the lux
Edition you have it apparently yeah it's
just there you can play it who's going
on sale also play first people have
played it and then people who went to a
review event and then we have a few cabs
in the office been playing a lot and I
don't even know where to start I do want
to get into the campaign because so much
the conversation around this game is
because of the hiccups to say the least
and multiplayer we'll get to the
campaign soon but let me kind of set the
stage for what's going on and you
haven't heard from so ever since
battlefront updates this YouTube channel
back in June did sort of a teaser for
how progression would work we did a
second of the lobby in June where Rob
use expressed worry that this game might
be pay to win flash forward to after an
alpha and into the beta and the play
first place session turns out yeah these
star cards are kind of in balancing a
game because they're not cosmetic items
that you can inadvertently paper or you
can pay for they are actual abilities in
the game and modifiers and buffs so that
was a problem in its own but then people
who were playing this game all week
whether through pre-ordering or playing
through play first etc express worried
because in the game you get you have to
use credits in game credits to buy
heroes a lot to most expensive ones or
Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker it's here
below that's like Palpatine Chewbacca
Leia etc in order to unlock those
players with 60,000 credits because the
game is now placed the base the credits
earned is based on playtime not skill or
wins or anything so they changed it was
EA has been saying that their plan is I
can't remember their statements because
they're very they're very vague but
basically they're saying whether or not
that's happening right now the plan is
to incorporate performance as well as
time but it's they said that it's
currently still focused mainly on time
so you were right I just wanted to say
that like they are stating that it will
have or will add factor in more of your
performance just as a state then so
someone did the math I forget the hotter
potato a reddit user said that if you
were to just save up credits over just
play time it would take you 40 actual
hours to unlock Vader or Skywalker and
one of them right and that's that's
assuming you're not spending credits on
weapon parts or literally anything right
the whole time and then uh so then it
just becomes the messaging is so mixed
because when this went to read it EA
responded saying we want it to be a per
sense of pride and accomplishment to
unlock these heroes people are like
forty hours is a pretty hefty task for
just one hero so everybody sick a Star
Wars hero right and it's not exactly
it's Vader there kind of surface and
also the again that's assuming you're
not spending credits on anything else
which there are a lot of things to spend
credits on but there are also crystals
which we can get to momentarily this is
just overall confusing Alessandro when
you came back from the review event
saying yeah we're not even 100% sure how
this works here and then you and Pete
that's the thing ei is kind of
expressing these sentiments that they
might not even understand because
they're that response on Redick it was
the most downloaded reddit post
allegedly and then people are like it
has to be because like reddit doesn't
keep track of that but literally the
second most downloaded reddit post was
someone asking to be downloaded if
you're yesterday the the response of EA
had negative six hundred and sixty-three
thousand points and that was yesterday
and I'm sure it's gone up as more news
has come out so EA because of all this
vitriol which i think is well-earned on
their part if that makes sense they
decreased the price take the credits
ending credits for Vader and scout all
heroes by seventy five percent so
ostensibly it would have taken seventy
five percent less time because like you
said most of the credits are earned on
playtime but whether that was a good
show of goodwill or not they also
decrease the can't finishing campaign
went from giving you twenty thousand
credits which was that's enough to get
you ID and versio or a third of the way
to Darth Vader Luke they decrease that
to five thousand unless you beat it
before that change right but that's
that's there's like a weird secondary
thing there because the five thousand is
how much it cost to unlock I didn't I
didn't yeah so it's like they were
saying okay we're bringing iDEN down to
five thousand so now we'll give the
campaign for that but because you're in
why should I be forced to pay for her if
you're just gonna give me the money it
cost unlocker just get the choice is
yours it's just saying the home the
choice but that's that's the that's the
the problem with that answer is like
you're giving me a bunch of credits and
you're saying that like I should be
spending this on iDEN right how is that
an excuse to lower the price you gave me
credit to the complete the campaign if
you're gonna make that statement then
make it an unlock from complete
everything immediately if life works
that way maybe I'll be getting paid a
lot more as the economy shrinks and
grows and you know whatever like this
[ __ ] doesn't work that way
yeah inflation doesn't seem to exist in
Star Wars Battlefront 2 or it does it
does it due to a fault
yes to a bigger fault thank you yeah
thanks sorry I'm not an economy major um
it's not that you need to be to
understand
another thing in EA dev okay so there's
two things that happen with EA dev so
first of all EA said that reddit post
and the negativity director gnam
encouraged them to decrease the heroes
and then dice is executive producer said
we are it's gonna be a constant state of
change like many games are today it's
kind of a game that service thing we're
gonna be always updating it but then
they drop the price those here with by
75% two days before launch they decrease
the camp the earning you get from
campaign to 5,000 to 20,000 like you
pizza because I didn't versio the
protagonist the campaign that we've seen
is now 5,000 but they also got so this
one person on Twitter who was claiming
to be an EA dev I won't mention the
Twitter name because I'm sure they've in
the recent news yesterday still got more
[ __ ] but I do have it up now they said
that they got 1,600 personal attacks and
seven death threats which they were
keeping track of for legal purposes and
they also said they're an EA dev but Co
taco and Waypoint both looked into it
further and there's no actual evidence
and based on EA EA says we take those
allegations very seriously we're gonna
look into it but as of now there's no
record that this person is an actual
person at EA and yesterday I was looking
at it and this person's profile on
Twitter said like hashtag we Rea kind of
implying there at EA they said my my
opinions my alone not my employers
they've mentioned game baffan their
profile and now I'm looking at it now
those EA things are gone yeah and the
profile is private so you have to follow
it and I'd follow them yesterday you
have to follow this profile in order to
see the tweets and they had deleted some
of those tweets um the person probably a
liar if you were right to the history of
their tweets they claimed to have
started working at EA and at multiple
different points of time they claimed to
work in multiple different departments
on my games that I didn't battlefront to
I think they said they were on a sports
game at first like with ultimate team
stuff no but yeah so regardless those
death threats and personal attacks I
mean I know there's a lot of vitriol
directed EA but for that person
specifically you may not be complete
they might not check out the no one has
any evidence of that person exists as
they claim to exist in with an e ace
organization AI it's just a pet but also
another EA dev
I don't have the name the other day was
stating that well people are like well
you have to play a [ __ ] ton of like [ __ ]
some of the games I'm like heroes
there's no other way to unlock them but
you can get because they're like you
can't buy heroes with real-world money
but then someone's like that's not true
because you can buy crystals which you
can buy loot crate's with which if you
get duplicates in loot crate's you
convert that to credits which you be
then spend on heroes so in an indirect
way you can spend real money on heroes
if you get duplicates in loot crate's be
one with crystals but you don't know how
much money you have to spend right
because it's because you don't know
you're gonna get in each pack yeah and
that's what a gambling aspect comes in
but EA keeps taking these somewhat half
measures and then you see another thing
that kind of balances it out in the
milestones for beating the campaign so
now we're all thinking that EA doesn't
know what it's doing so I am so
exhausted of this game so there you go
yeah so there's $100 so we did that test
just to see and you seen the upper right
hand corner there is almost through
30,000 credits just that is strictly
from paying $100 and getting duplicates
and getting actually there's a Duke
within the right there over 200 credits
actually also getting credits from loot
crate's and I'm talking about like a
thousand credits so it's just yeah like
everything about this system you can
just like funnel into opening a loot
crate yes so the package is right there
that is everything about this
progression system is just funneling
into opening and the act of opening and
purchasing these loot crate's right
whether it whether it's through crystals
whether it's through credits that's all
this game is about and their lives the
problem in that what game is like this
where it's is a hundred percent about
the act of opening a loot crate it's
such a confluence of three shitty
practices a it's it's just
microtransactions to begin with which
they can be done well like in something
like overwatch or I think Rainbow six
siege doesn't really well in the two
years since its release and they have
another third year plan they're doing
something right but it's also these are
pay2win aspects because it's actually
affecting your abilities and modifiers
not just cosmetics and aesthetics but
also like Pete mentioned and you
mentioned these loot crate's are very
much it's gambling you don't know what
you're gonna get in them in titanfall we
mentioned before you
no you're getting a scorch prime
cosmetic you know you're buying this
North Star cosmetic you know you're
getting this weapon camouflage and this
who knows what you're gonna get in this
crate that you just spent you spent
real-world money to get crystals to buy
this crate and you're hoping for
something new or you're hoping for
duplicates that you can transform into
credits to buy these heroes to
circumvent that 40 hours that it takes I
don't know that anybody's done the math
since they decrease the milestones I'm
sure it's not too different because I
still want to look into whether other
milestones and rewards changed aside
from the campaign Rob you said you
didn't see much yet but maybe we can
look back at our old footage and then
look at the new stuff now yeah it's
tough to do because it's it's hard to
gauge you know you talk about time and
then now they're saying though there is
a little bit performance that affects
your reward for matches but it's just
it's legit hard to determine and I think
that's that says a lot about this
progression and that I like to figure
that's that's why it's meant to be so
it's meant to be so muddy and unclear
that all your mind goes to because these
systems these systems are so complex
that all your mind goes to is well I
guess I got out more loot crate's yes
that's all I can say like it's yeah snap
JT in the YouTube chat was saying the
division did well to like I do want to
kind of if we have time to talk about
games that are doing post release well
because like we said 2017 is a year
something such that so many games that
our early XS are more complete than some
games that have a full release $60 other
games have microtransactions where you
know who knows when people going to stop
paying money and throw in their wallets
to the screen for Battlefront 2 or I
don't know it's another shadow of war
which has also like actual things that
affect your abilities in the campaign in
the single-player campaign in the very
end of the game right and that not as
egregious as what they're doing
Battlefront 2 but the thing that those
share in common is that you know Lord of
the Rings is going to pull people from a
different demographic that always play
games star wars probably even more so is
gonna pull people that don't always play
games so you know we talked about it the
other week ea just an alt Ultimate Team
alone made was like 1.3 billion dollars
in micro transactions like people can
complain all they want and downvote
comments all they want yeah in the end
is gonna care about the money they're
making which sounds obvious but if you
really want to get this to stop I would
say stop paying for games like this or
stop paying for my card transactions but
at the same time we were talking about
us before the show went live if you're
watching this right now
I don't think you're the kind of person
maple okay that I'm generalizing but I
think the people who are whales with the
industry calls and that's spend the most
money on these are people who just kind
of accept it for what it is and might
not go to GameSpot or on to Reddit or to
Waypoint Kotaku the key difference here
is that people who might be used to that
you could theorize would also be used to
it because they've seen this on mobile
where a lot of non-traditional games go
to play games but those games on mobile
tend to be free they don't tend to be as
releases with all this stuff integrated
so centrally to the rest of the games
and again there's a Star Wars and it's
gonna pull in so many people who
wouldn't who might not normally be
exposed to microtransactions who come in
say oh this is how games are I haven't
played a gamer since five years ago I
just know that if you look through all
this you can find [ __ ] like the
Starfighter assault mode and like all
this other stuff that is great about it
but it's just it's it's all lost behind
this veil only confusion again and I
have to bring it back this idea of a
funnel going back to loot crate's
because all these systems in play like
nothing is easily accessible everything
is like pulling you back into into the
idea of opening a loot crate like you
get rewards during a match you have to
like legit I can't just like continue
playing an exit multiplayer right
because I yeah I have to exit the game
and go to the milestones and get my
reward now Morey had a game so I might
as well go open up a loot crate but like
anything you earn in-game is always
requiring you to play like you just
think about you so many times side and
just focus on crates and so you have to
do like how many times like like you
think of other multiplayer games where
it's like you get an unlock and like it
automatically like tosses it on your no
story yeah right let's go let's go let's
keep playing yeah same goes for the
Arcade Mode that people keep complaining
about here a lot of complaint today is
that the arcade mode allows you to win
rewards but I don't know how many times
or how many hours after giving up say
you just want to play that game and have
the frustration of competitive online
like just behind you you just want to
focus on playing a
fairly fun game mode you hit a ceiling
and the game says no you got to wait now
three hours in order to actually get
credit wait seriously yeah but you ain't
gonna get rewarded for it cuz we've been
over everything else so I was kind of
I'm like already exhausted or smaller
I'm already exhausted by the
microtransactions conversation as I'm
sure a lot of people are but it makes
you wait to earn more from playing yeah
yeah yeah the way three hours you
already paid for the game that's a that
is that's the one that's the other thing
from mobile games right yeah oh there's
like it's an exhaustion it's a
frustration factor that is so mobile
game driven where it's like you get a
taste even the milestones start K often
like even the milestones are like here's
all these rewards you're getting that's
a finite amount of milestones where
you're gonna get past that and then
you're so now you're even dipping
further as far as you're your reward
factor of how many credits are getting
where you're gonna hit I think like a at
some point this roadblock and you can be
like I'm not getting credits as fast as
I used to be getting for what until you
can play again you mean so you can play
arcade as much as you want but you can
only get up to five run trains right
I'll make it up to imagine and that's a
15 hour cooldown I think they may have
changed be surprised if came back look
okay guys we hear you so if you want to
pay a thousand crystals you can keep
earning credits and there's and there's
one other thing that you as you were
listening all these like somewhat
responses from EA that one that just
makes me frustrated is somewhat of the
response that I gathered was that you
know it's it's a video game it's an
online community the currency it's
naturally gonna need changing and and
and inflation needs to be adjust and so
forth that is such [ __ ] when you
think about someone who who did
everything that they wanted pre-ordered
the game in early access just wants to
play Luke Skywalker pays the sixty
thousand credits and gets Luke Skywalker
and then they flip it and they say now
it's actually twenty thousand credits
that's appalling you can't just like
spin that like I said if it's an it's a
natural like evolution of a video game
it's not like this is a thing like like
Eve where there's like an actual
economist who works on the game and it's
an evolving economy that like grows and
changes with and always-online like
world it's not the same thing as just
setting prices it in a game that it's
not an economy in the real world so it's
not going to shift and Eve all like I
don't know and all and like they've made
enough games or it shouldn't be that
hard to figure out how much something
should cost I really don't think it
should be that hard yeah the hotter
potato did this excel sheet that was
pretty in-depth this is based on the
fact this is based before that change
when Luke and Darth favorable fifteen
thousand credits Palpatine Leia
Chewbacca or ten and iDEN was five
thousand um assuming they weren't really
death the United States minimum wage is
$7.25 would be 13 hours and 79 Wow
doesn't include taxes being taken out no
no I don't think so Donal so hours at
minimum wage to buy 60 trooper Cates is
almost 14 so game play hours to buy 60
trooper crates is 157 at best at best so
based on this it's currently 11.4 times
more efficient with your time to spend
money rather than play battlefront to
that and that's even that's before the
change so I'm sure it's not as bad now
but it's still you know like the game is
here like again you paid $60 this game
it's not free-to-play like you mentioned
mobile games that's the whole trade-off
it's you can pay to save time where you
could play and just not spend anything
and that's your prerogative it's also
not an altruistic work of art I mean
that's made to and and yeah and it's uh
it just seems like everything based on a
math is devoted to trying to get you to
pay and if you want to just play like
you do in a game it's gonna take a long
long time you just play their video
games and nothing about this one I'm you
know that's what I'm doing as well the
fact that you're pulling up a freaking
spreadsheet like coincides
with I think a final point of why this
upsets me the most is that sorry
somewhat super-dee in the use of chess
and just by crystals on the darknet okay
you can just use Bitcoin yeah it's gonna
bring that in soon the fact that we're
all adults trying to figure this out
right speak for and it's and it's Star
Wars yeah we're like you're there are
children playing this game and there is
no freaking way that they are like a kid
you cost math judge my bills it's
honestly it's a funnel into the idea of
opening a loot crate and like I'm just
trying my best think like as a kid would
and it's like I need to get more loot
crate's and she knows how luke rates
more money open up and open people are
gonna give the crate and they're just
talking is this year over the holidays
I'm so when I first started offered like
okay we know a wants to make money we're
no we know there's gonna be micro
transactions so it was it was one of two
things either ei doesn't even or ei
knows what it's doing and it's just
trying to hide the fact that it's being
exploitative or ei doesn't even
understand battlefronts economy III
think it's both I think they're
obviously they're obviously trying to
squeeze money out but I also think they
have no idea what they're doing right
now they're trying to figure out how to
make money and please people in the
public image and like reconcile these
things that people have been exposing
but again I think they're just as
confused as we are with this economy
not a good sign of routine that hasn't
even officially released it yeah they've
had statements were like nothing is you
know every comment like no they did like
I read at AMA today which just sifting
through some of the the comments from
them or responses is just like what
you've been hearing as far as like we've
heard you we're looking into it we're
doing this and that and it's just it's
even comments just like yeah like we you
know this this the currency system like
we we we realized that like it wasn't
like it wasn't like finalized at launch
and all these things where it's just
what you say it's just like a difficult
to find
if it's not too complicated to begin
with but a lot of these comments too I
think are like contradictory where it's
like we just took the the data from the
beta and implemented it like how does
that make sense
you and I were talked about this
yesterday like they claimed to be
listening and caring about what fans
think but if they were doing that after
the beta the Alpha the play first eat
the e3 showing we wouldn't be in this
situation if they were really listening
the hero card like the expensive heroes
is only one piece of the problem and
that was sort of treated like a band-aid
for that as the whole is treating the
whole game and it's like no that's
that's actually just one of many issues
in a huge problematic systems like the
fulcrum of people's argument against
this game right now because it's so easy
to say like it's tangible it's like oh
I'm from 60,000 to 15 whatever it is
15,000 it's still gonna take a lot of
time to unlock all these heroes I can't
believe they put a cool-down
on a mode as well so I'm like yeah so at
first I was like well a lot of game like
there are a lot of games to have daily
challenges that cool down the next day
but those are not you can play so you
can play any mode you want and beat
these challenges like again I keep
bringing up because I've been playing a
lot Rainbow six siege has done they have
loot crate's now but it's all cosmetic
what like unless you're getting
operators which is just you could still
play and it's still fair and how many
credits you earn not credit sorry now
and it's called macking but you can play
any game mode and complete these
challenges there's a cool-down on the
daily challenges because their daily
challenges you can keep playing any game
mode and earning credits where as you
said in battlefront you could keep
playing this mode and not get any
rewards well I mean it's like destiny
you have your like chores that you do
your like daily your weekly or daily
things that you do and then presented
that way but it's like this is a daily
activity and there's still other things
you can do although some people would
argue there's no I'm just doing destiny
- we can talk about that at a different
time and I and there is like a
diminishing returns effect on like what
you get out of if you were going to
repeat that activity right but but this
is like just an arcade and like this
yeah well once is when you're talking
with doesn't once you've finished all
those chores you could still go to
another mode and still get some sort of
reward from it battlefront is saying no
you can play this mode if you have
fun but you will not get anything out of
it destiny matter it wouldn't matter if
the whole purpose of the games but but
also but also in destiny correct me if
I'm wrong no matter what you're really
doing you're so leveling up right and
and gaining something out of it even if
it's not like an exotic and so into you
you look at something you know there cuz
there are many ways you can get
different things right with with like
the weapons for instance either you luck
out on an opening one a crate with a
weapon or the last weapon with some of
the cooler and I would say the best
weapons like really like heavy duty like
explosive round sniper rifles get 500
kills as a specialist class and that's
only killing and like actual players
like that is just gonna take you a
really really long time that's just
gonna take you a long time you know and
you'd like to think of like something
like that is is it's not as simple as
I'm trying to correlate that to like
destiny works like well I'm always still
at least you know that you're somewhat
leveling up like there also there's no
like the only real world's money that
you like you can't buy sweet business
with dollars you can buy cosmetic stuff
with dollars so it's it's like that's
why I'm I didn't know about the cooldown
and I'm just like that is just the
cherry on top of all of it yeah I guess
so I'm most trying to get is is you're
you're now requiring me to play one way
for a very very long time I'm not gonna
get I'm getting battle points but
there's no point of me becoming kylo Ren
or flying a ship or doing all there's
other activities within Battlefront
that are enjoyable and keep the game
lively I am focused on one class that's
all I'm gonna do I'm just gonna shoot
people with this gun like that's just
that's gonna take a really long time
it's just it's frustrating as hell
anonymous mink in the YouTube chat says
this is partly GameSpot's fault bemmon
IGN could have helped put an end to
these types of games and I started
putting them out like I just said I
think the majority people spending money
in these games probably might not watch
the
lobbie every week when we're ranting
about this stuff yeah I mean we do our
best to kind of call these stay out and
our audience tends to agree with us yeah
that doesn't translate to a loss of
sales my uncle Jeff who loves Star Wars
isn't gonna go to LA be like [ __ ] I'm
not getting this Star Wars gaming room
yeah I wish we could stop it I don't
think it's gonna stop anytime soon I
think people they're making enough money
off of these outside of the circles that
we are all collectively in right now
even people who do understand it and
aren't used to it are just gonna keep
doing it it's our fault if you're
watching and you don't want these games
to to keep happening I would say don't
spend money on micro transactions I hate
that it's an afterthought I did want to
talk about the campaign but that's what
sucks I think that's indicative of
that's is like that it's not the
campaign's fault
and like but also it's such a big part
of the conversation these these shitty
predatory practices that it's
overshadowing almost every other
conversation we could be having about
the game the campaign like you know in
the end when you beat it it's still tied
to the micro transactions in the
milestone and how you buy I didn't and
so so much on Luke we're lucky enough to
get the thirty twenty thousand credits
from beating campaign thirty thousand
whatever was before the change so now
they could spend on other heroes but
that's that's a smaller campaign this
case the whole game is so heavily tied
into Luke ray said you're even reminded
through cuts cut scenes during the
campaign that you are getting luke rates
and that collectables in the game are
also tied into getting credits so you're
getting milestones for like you know
it's reminding you like well here's the
you get this milestone for completing
this mission but there's also two other
hid and milestones little crates that
you use your droid - open up and those
will give you credits which everything
is filtered back into the multiplayer
but but what's frustrating is like I for
one was really excited for this
I guess we're talking about campaign now
campaign yeah I wanted to see this
untold story right of like a fraternity
I but like even the cutscenes there and
get like every time it's initiated at
the end of each mission it's a it's a
prompts that's like immediately starting
and during dialogue and it's saying like
you just got up loot crate exit the
campaign if you want to open it and see
what's in it
you want to know what's in the loot
crate's that you get crafting parts now
it's not just that so you get like say I
think there's 12 missions I'll just tell
you you get all these loot crate's half
I want to say let half maybe a little
less than half of all the star cards
that you get and the loot crate's are
oriented around the Luke Skywalker star
card Luke Skywalker is locked right and
cost twenty thousand credits so you're
not really getting any so you're not
really getting that whole a half the
star cards are unless you all you know
you played a campaign first right that's
how most people play any kind of game
like a shooter that's how I play it you
you're getting stuff for a character you
have none left yet and it's so hard to
talk about all this stuff without
sounding confusing and sifting through
so many different currencies and how
these affect that and how the campaign
is going to affect multiplayer and vice
versa and I think that's half the point
I think he aid in that respect and knew
that if they obfuscated enough or made
this hazy or that kind of foggy that it
would encourage people just say [ __ ] it
I'm gonna save time and brainpower and
just pay for later by getting crystals
to get crates to get duplicates to get
credits playing the game just play no
again play another video game or let
this or play this game the campaign I
don't know whatever
do what you want use your money however
you want I'm not sure I'm not gonna tell
you not buy this game but I'm not gonna
buy it I think that's the show so that's
it yeah I was gonna talk about campaign
but again I think that's just pretty
much all we could say about that will
front to right now is all sound rose
review and progress up will it be soon
dude that's been up it's about not be
you're been a gamespot.com review in
progress review in progress did I not
say sorry oh you did I'm sorry oh my god
losing your mind yeah so that's our show
pretty much I do want to get to a few
other things like I said if you want to
go check out Alessandro's review in
progress for the game I think it's just
six out of ten right now rightfully so
based on just a lot of this [ __ ] that EA
is doing with it but if you want to go
more in depth go read that go watch a
video review on YouTube and GameSpot
that's our show thank you for everybody
joining in the YouTube and twitch and
GameSpot chats as always we welcome your
company and thank you for the people
that are sending in questions and
comments throughout the show I do want
to talk about extra life one more time
this is our last lobby before we started
Friday at noon that's November 17th noon
pacific time we are going to kick off
our extra life lives
for those of you if this is your first
time it's a like a video game industry
tradition every year all proceeds to
these live streams will just go to sick
children oh yeah
and we personally here at GameSpot will
be donating to UCSF Benioff Children's
Hospital here in the Bay Area so you can
go there to tinyurl.com /gs extra life
2017 or you can follow the hashtag gs
extra life on twitter we'll be talking
about it all week and weekend so a San
Francisco office the UK office and the
Australia office will be handing it off
we'll be kicking things off and for 24
hours I believe and then UK will be
going for 12 hours and then Australia
will finish it off for 24 hours
oh yeah pretty much everybody on staff
will be coming up in Canberra to play
Callie and I will be kicking off with
Joey and Sam we're gonna play some
Pokemon games maybe some maybe some like
Skyrim on switch I have no idea it'll be
out that day definitely not gonna be
battlefront 2 anymore I think we're
still finalizing our list yeah but it'll
be a fun time so if you have if you have
some a few extra dollars to throw at us
so we can throw it to the hospitals feel
free to come and stop by even if you
don't we'd love to come have you hang
out like make us do dumb stuff but don't
make us eat anything gross please go
I'll do that oh no what is throwing up
when I'm on stream I swear to god I'll
try not to but yeah come hang out with
us that starts again noon Pacific time
on the 20 on the 17th right before the
u.s. Thanksgiving week so it'll be a
good time to prepare for vacation Peter
and I are playing from midnight Friday
to 6:00 a.m. got the graveyard shift
yeah it's a marathon
we'll be going for four hours the
beginning will switch off for a few
other people come hang out oh and we
also have a bunch of giveaways I think
the three items that our social team
wants to highlight is the 10th
anniversary Bioshock statue we're giving
away an Xbox one and also what's the
third one was an assassin's creed
origins kind of bundle which oddly
enough I don't know that it comes to the
game it's like a statue art book a lot
of like behind-the-scenes stuff but we
have a ton we have a huge list so we'll
be pretty much doing one like every hour
if not more often so come hang out you
could win one of those things and in the
meantime stay tuned a game spot for
whenever our full Battlefront two of you
happens GT sport reviews up now that you
got to play more the online stuff well I
didn't review it
friend GameSpot curved you didn't do the
review I didn't even publish a review in
progress but you played it oh we talked
on the lobby that's like juries here's
what this game is we add James spoon
bangs freelancer out of Australia that's
a civilizing yeah who had the time to
put 50 hours plus game that's not get to
the championship events to kick off last
week and we have our review in the
meantime go play rocket League on switch
go play doom on switch we haven't played
it yet if you have a switch okay clicker
come on don't play - yeah there you go
there you have it we will see you
hopefully on Friday for extra life and
all weekend otherwise as far as us for
our concern we'll see you next week same
time 11:00 a.m. Wednesday see you then
[Music]
you